[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's be honest, you're
an awesome engineer
with an awesome app, and you
are using threading to the max.
Sadly though, managing all
those individual threads
and assigning work
between them is
causing you to lose your hair.
My name is Colt
McAnlis, and please,
don't join the bald club.
Instead use the
thread pools class
which is an ideal primitive
for breaking up lots of work
into little buckets.
See, historically,
it was commonplace
that applications would use
a dedicated thread model.
That is, one thread that only
deals with database rights,
while a separate thread only
handles streaming of music,
and a third one only
handles networking.
These setups are OK because
the amount of work per thread
isn't that large,
and it's OK to handle
this work in sequential order.
But there reaches a point where
this model starts to fall over.
Say, for example, that you've
got 40 bitmaps to decode,
and each decode takes like
four milliseconds or something.
Putting all of this work on
a single dedicated thread
is a bad idea, since it'll take
80 milliseconds total to get
all that work done in
a sequential fashion.
On the other hand, if
you created 10 threads
and let each one
decode four bitmaps,
then you'd end up only
taking 16 milliseconds total.
But then, of course,
you run into the problem
of how to properly pass the work
around between those threads,
schedule that work, and then
managing of those threads.
Before you start stressing out
about writing all that code,
don't worry.
This is exactly what
ThreadPoolExecuter primitive
is for.
Basically, this
class will just let
you spin up a number of
threads and toss blocks of work
to execute on it.
ThreadPoolExecuter handles
all of the heavy lifting
of spinning up the
threads, load balancing
work across those
threads, and even killing
those threads when they
have been idle for a while.
Basically, it handles
all the heavy lifting
of super parallel
processing on your behalf.
All you have to do
is split up the work.
But there's a small caveat here.
How many threads should
your thread pool have?
I mean, technically
speaking, you
have the ability to create
as many threads as you want.
But that's not ideal.
See, CPUs can only
execute a certain number
of threads in parallel.
Once you get above that
number, then the CPU
has to start deciding
which threads
get the next free block
of processor time,
based on how important
they are, which
means that if you keep
eventually adding threads,
you'll hit a break-even
point, where your computation
isn't getting any faster,
even though the number
of threads that you have
has increased significantly.
And it's also important to
note that each of these threads
aren't free.
Each thread costs you about
64k of memory in minimum,
and that adds up
quickly, especially
in situations where
the call stacks can
start growing pretty large.
As such, your app needs
to find a sweet spot
between the number of cores and
the point of diminishing return
with the number of threads.
Thankfully, once again, the
ThreadPoolExecuter class
has got you covered.
When creating your
thread pool, you
can specify the number
of initial threads
and the number of
maximum threads.
As the workload in the
thread pool changes,
it'll scale the number of
alive threads to match.
Oh, and a quick note--
the value returned from
get available processors
may not reflect
the number of physical
cores in the device.
See, some devices have
CPUs that will deactivate
one or more cores, depending
on the system load,
to save battery.
So if your device has two CPUs,
but one of them is asleep,
this value could return one.
And, of course, thread
pools won't solve
all of your threading problems.
As mentioned earlier,
unless you're
dealing with lots and lots
of work packets all the time,
this thing's kind of overkill.
It's best to use things like
HandlerThreads or AsyncTask
loaders for specific
types of work blocks
and only throw the
massive computing
problems at the thread pool.
And for you power
users out there,
remember that Renderscript
might be a better alternative
to large-scale parallel
work on Android devices,
but that's a whole
separate set of videos
that we haven't gotten into yet.
And don't forget that Systrace
is an amazingly powerful tool
that lets you
visualize how work is
flowing through the threads
in your application.
It's a great way to validate
that things are working
as intended and also see all
the other crazy threads that
are being worked on by
other parts of your app.
And that's the trick with
performance, isn't it?
I mean, you can
make assumptions.
But things don't always
work the way you think,
which is why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns videos.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community to ask a lot
of hard threading
questions as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]